tonight
i'm going to talk about the ministry for
the future
and cop26 and what i have
learned since cop26
is it's a
fire hose of information as we all know
and now a lot of it's getting aimed my
way by a kind of a category error
because i am an english major and a
science fiction writer
and um that's all i am so
if somebody is actually coming to me to
find
solutions for climate change then we're
in terrible trouble
um and it's worried me a lot um but i'm
beginning to see
uh things that i can do even as the
cardboard cutout
for the minister for the future
i was at um glasgow inside the blue zone
my hangout was the un futures lab when
they were my home base my my buddies
they took care of me and they gave me a
closet to sleep in if i had to take a
nap and they taught me things
and then and and i was really quite
comfortable there and it was a
tremendous education and at one point my
my main host a woman named coco warner
has worked at every one of the cops for
the un she said stan
who invited you here
and i thought it was her
and i was looking at her going oh my god
i don't know anything i don't even know
why i'm here
and i had to investigate i had to
pretend i looked there and i said
um
well the invocation came from nigel
topping whose official title was the
high champion for crop 26 because the
british government likes their titles a
lot
the high champion was his official title
good guy and he was the one who invited
me and he gave me a red pass which meant
that in the blue zone i could go
anywhere i wanted
and this wasn't true for most people who
are observers you would get a yellow
badge and you wouldn't go into the
negotiating sessions that was for people
with red or blue and blue was just the
u.n itself
so there i was with this red badge which
nigel topping had given me
and i decided that the rest of the thing
being kind of a trade show for each
nation would buy a pavilion in a giant
convention center and i i don't know if
you all have seen pictures of the blue
zone in a cop but it's somewhat like a
trade show or a circus or a
um
it's or a science fiction convention and
anybody who knows science fiction
conventions uh one of those for two days
is not bad for two weeks you have got to
be kidding me
and yet
so i began to go to negotiating sessions
any kind of negotiating session and this
is very interesting
there were more than 50 percent women in
their 30s and 40s lawyers diplomats
scientists
they were working a document they were
editing together they were revising
editing
proposing
in
this is one kind of session anyway
document editing
by a ferociously concentrated cheerful
but meticulous
um
for my point of view young women
and with some elderly brit diplomats who
were staggering around with a limp and a
breeze case from bretton woods and it
was it was very cute how calm they were
compared to
everybody else there
and
i was impressed by that and
then in other negotiating sessions in in
very polite tones of voice people were
arguing over money
and the developed world was holding back
their bags of money and the developing
world was saying you promised it and we
need it and in polite voices you were
seeing the incredible tight-fistedness
the just self-destructive
tight-fistedness
of all of the developed countries who
had promised money in the paris
agreement and aren't coughing it up
one of the developing nations diplomats
said to me the
the sewage budget for new york city is
35 billion dollars a year and the
developed world has just given us 20
billion when they promised 100 billion
and even 100 billion is
not enough but 20 billion is ridiculous
and that's where they were at so this
was a depressing part of glasgow for
sure but to see it all happen real time
i began to understand
cop is just a place to come and look at
each other on an annual basis to see
what we're doing
in the rest of the world the rest of the
year it is not the place of solving
problems
it's there's no legally binding treaties
there and there's no sheriff nor a jail
if you were to break the promises or
even to leave the agreement outright
um it has some beautiful mechanisms in
it it has an injunction to permanently
improve each time they meet everybody's
supposed to up their promises and make
things better and so it's like a ratchet
or a come along
each year you ratchet up the
intensity of the promises but their
promises only and i began to think it's
like a marriage
this is what you got to think of it as
you promised to spend your whole life
together and to do productive things
together
five years later you break up nobody
throws you in jail um hopefully and and
so what you've got at this point is a
world in which all the nation states
have in effect joined into a
a group marriage or something like a
marriage a set of promises to behave in
certain ways together
and there's no place to move if you get
a divorce it's like one of those
stories from my my my soviet agent
during the ussr days he and his wife had
divorced 10 years before but they were
still in the same apartment well the
world's going to be like that we can't
get away from each other and there's we
got i'm going to come back to talking
about the nation-state system
so
i'm
everybody i guess the last things i
would say about cop well there's a few
observations
it was a militarized site so the uk
government was really worried because of
world leaders coming or because of
seattle 1999
um it was behind barbed wire and tank
stoppers the it was on the river clyde
so that there were zodiacs out on the
river with
military people and machine guns there
were helicopters just hovering
oftentimes especially during the marches
and the scottish people were loving
their marches
i stood next to bill mckibben as the
start of one march we were like at the
parade marshals you know off you go off
you go and they were seeing mckibben
who's very recognizable going oh my god
you know it's saint bill is blessing
this march
and they had taken their kids out of
school out of preschool it was a family
affair everybody had made banners and
posters
it's quite beautiful um
ten thousand people on friday a hundred
thousand people on saturday and about a
hundred people in us in a non-sanctioned
march where there were many more police
than there were marchers and i joined
all three of them
um but i have to admit that the big one
on saturday i only enjoined him because
i needed to cross the street and there
was no other way and so i went out there
and i joined a group of nurses and we
chatted for a while and i flowed
downstream for about 100 yards or so and
then got off on the other side and went
my way
but it was quite beautiful to see the
civic engagement of the scottish people
with being the hosts of cop
and then
the results from it
were good as far as they go
but every diplomat and scientists there
the more they knew about the cop system
and the world the more scared they were
because although it is an admirable
system and way better than nothing at
all it's too slow because it's built on
a consensus model every nation there has
to agree to every sentence
you saw an example of this in the last
hours where they were going to phase out
coal and at the last moment in china and
india and several other nations said um
oh gosh we can't do that um
we refuse and they went into a huddle an
overtime a couple hours of intense
lobbying and they came out well we'll
face down call and then everybody signed
off on it well this kind of consensus
model although admirable it's like the
general assembly without the security
council so it's a true
international body of nations you've got
all the people there but since they have
to all agree to every statement
as admirable as it is it's too slow
compared to the crisis i reckoned on the
train ride down to london that if we had
this is such a guess but it's a science
fiction exercise if we had 40 years
the cop procedures might work but we
only have 10.
so they're not enough and we're and and
we and i left cop thinking we are in
terrible trouble and nothing in the four
months since then has made me change my
mind on that we are in terrible trouble
but that doesn't mean
what that means also needs to be
unpacked
so um
in the months since then i thought it
would slack off it didn't slack off
and i began to
get quite nervous about being helpless
to suggest or say anything but what i
began to realize is i could take
somebody um
who were was interested in talking to me
about topic x
and i could connect them up with
somebody else who was an expert on topic
x
and they didn't know about each other
because the world is too big and that's
interesting in and of itself that
although there's lots of good work being
done
not only is there no coordinating force
that's making priorities and and linking
things up together and all that but
that's almost impossible in the in the
world that we're in who would do that
i'm involved with the un's 50-year
forecasting group and the un is doing
their damnedest to maybe rate and
prioritize
they're overwhelmed they can't do it you
would have to
postulate a a ministry for the future
that was a really good budget
and a huge team of people trying to sort
and connect and that doesn't really
exist but as my cardboard cutout
imitation of a minister i can now begin
to connect people who should know about
each other just recently
i met the woman who runs california's 30
by 30 program
30 percent of california protected land
for wild creatures by the year 2030
amazing idea and i thought it would
never happen in my lifetime and already
they're shooting for 2030 and and they
say well after we hit 30 by 30 we're
going to shoot for 50 by 50 and then
we'll have a healthy biosphere and
california is an exemplary space as you
know and teaches the rest of the world
how to do these things and the rest of
the world teaches california
it's a super promising thing but she had
never met the head of the pacific
conservation league
which without this 30 by 30 framework
had nevertheless been working on similar
causes
for the last
25 years
and i was able to say oh gosh you need
you know you're both in the sacramento
area need to meet they've since met it's
a productive meeting things will go on
uh it's been a pleasure for me
and when i was talking with this
jennifer norris head of 30 by 30 what we
began to discover together
is you need
the framework tail the frame tail
because everybody's individual efforts
are going to be too small to matter or
to change the world and you do what you
can and you're thinking well i'm i'm
swimming again i'm crossing the
pacific by swimming i'm in terrible
trouble here
because it's such a small drop in the
bucket or drop in the ocean but if you
see that
you're part of a larger story where
everybody else is also putting say
another analogy a brick in the wall you
work on your brick you know there's a
wall you'll stick your brick into it
this is a crucial realization for
keeping spirits up solidarity mutual aid
and it's funny when you think about this
wall analogy for one thing i build my
walls in maine out of glacial cobble
it's the worst possible rock to make
walls out of hilariously bad and every
every spring i go out there with my wife
and find my last year's wall has fallen
down just from the freezing thaw cycle
um and gravity
and that's the kind of material we have
right and also there's no architect and
there's no stone mason but nevertheless
this is how um
group
projects work
everybody knows what needs to be built
and so you just put your brick in the
wall and you feel that the concept of
the wall is helping so i think that
that's another reason why ministry for
the future has had people had a hunger
for that story that if everything that
is possibly be done gets done then even
the bad stuff won't be able to stop us
from getting to a good place